a coronary angioplasty procedure is also
known as percutaneous coronary
intervention
the procedure is done on blood vessels
called coronary arteries
they Supply your heart muscle with
oxygen
the goal is to restore blood flow if a
substance called plaque has
significantly narrowed these vessels
a wire mesh tube called a stent may be
placed in the treated area the stent
helps keep the coronary artery open
your doctor will choose the proper size
stent which is compressed over a balloon
the stent will be moved into the artery
over the same guide wire when the
balloon is inflated the stent will
expand and lock into place
after the balloon catheter is taken out
the stent will stay in place to hold the
artery open